how does a bodysuit work why Wow like
I'm in a bad parity of a/c a music video
hi my name is Kirk helping you don't
know now you know your life is different
now Donald Trump is the President of the
United States
don't have anything else to say here are
nine things that my dog does better than
Donald Trump she listens down chicken
shake shams correctly she flees she
doesn't scream when she watches TV she
doesn't try to disrupt things that she
should not be a part of she brushes her
hair she doesn't cover him Russia she
waits for a woman to ask to be kissed
before she kisses her ham key thank you
she doesn't use Twitter well there you
go there are some things that my dog
does better than Donald Trump let me
know of your pets do anything better
than Donald Trump in the comments down
below we're going to subscribe to this
YouTube channel click that little Bell
button because it notifies you when I
post videos because it is so
inconsistent it's Monday Wednesday
Friday technically but also not so just
click that bell so you're notified I
give this video a thumbs up if you liked
it at all cuz I liked it maybe I can
make more videos like this but I'll only
do it if you click the thumbs up I'm
I'll probably do it anyway
I don't know she knows how to wear
casual clothes